all right so good afternoon everyone
welcome to this panel as I said on
gender and cars which begins the
afternoon we'll go from 2:15 to 4:00 and
I'll take this opportunity to introduce
our speakers and I'll introduce them in
the order in which they'll make their
presentations and then just say a couple
of things about the broader questions
that Dalit feminists and the kind of
critiques about the relationship between
gender and castes have thrown up which
makes it I think an especially powerful
and important site for rethinking both
the politics of caste
today and also for thinking about the
longer term legacies of anti caste
thought panelists today are sadani
whose Dean of Social Sciences and in the
history department at the BR Ambedkar
Open University next will be J bro just
Singh who teaches in the Women and
Gender Studies department at st. John
Fisher College and then we will have
sweetener Ulla
who is a clinical associate professor of
law at New York University in that order
and just some of the conversations that
I hope will take place in this panel and
especially in conversation between the
participants themselves
it seems to me that questions that have
emerged or have been put on the table by
Dalit feminists today have been
particularly important I think in doing
three particular things one is that
Dalit feminists who began to organize in
the mid to late 1990s put forward a
particularly important critique on the
one hand of the forms of caste
patriarchy that they themselves
experienced within both the within the
Belet movement and within the context of
their own family and intimate
relationships at the same time they
proposed and made very strong critiques
about the history of Indian feminism as
it had constructed itself and launched a
sort of critique and extensive critique
of the kinds of fundamental categories
that Indian feminists
supposed in their own assumptions that
women's experiences their social
experiences and their forms of
politicization and and activism were
somehow similar and are shared across
across the nation and in Dalit feminists
specifically drew on longer term
traditions of anti caste thought drawing
on people like filet on Betty are on
embed good and on people like that abide
Shinde in madrastra who had been one of
the first in 1882 to propose a very
strong critique both of caste patriarchy
on the one hand and then more broadly of
colonialism and and and Brahmanism and
so and one of the important arguments
that has been put forward by the live
feminists and I think something that all
of our panelists will be addressing
today is the relationship between the
social reproduction of caste on the one
hand and its sexual reproduction and so
the relationship between the sexual and
the social reproduction of cost I think
is something very important the second
and something that speaker will speak to
today's specifically are the new
traditions of feminist activism that
delyth feminists specifically have made
use of and this I think really has to do
with drawing on the testimonial going
before international bodies especially
the UN but more broadly making use of a
kind of Human Rights discourse in a
sense to short-circuit the kind of
predilections in the foreclosures of the
Indian nation state and actually
addressing their critiques so with that
in mind let me ask professor sadani to
begin conversation today good afternoon
everybody I'm really happy and I feel it
my privilege to be here and this August
a board of learning Columbia University
which was being a dream to me to study
here but a dream come in a different way
to be with you share my thoughts with
you and why I'm using this word dream
it's a dream for the Dalits
that women especially who is born in a
poor family being born to a laborer in
the coal mines who could not afford
education to his children a children I
am being the youngest of them and it's a
dream for anybody like me to educate in
higher education institutions but I
could make it because of the affirmative
policy of Indian governments and we say
'zed way the father of the Constitution
Baba Saheb Ambedkar morning I was
referring to Pratap ji about the
reservation policy he says that it is
important to the lives of thousands and
millions of millions of Dalits in India
in South Asia to better their lives and
to be on par with other individuals and
today I'm going to talk about Dalits and
people's movements in Andhra Pradesh
that women perspective this thanks and
coma for giving a tone to the panel and
exactly some of the points which I
raised as a part of representation may
answer them I'm going to talk about the
delete' women perspectives
contextualizing and the region which I
come from andhra pradesh talking about
some of the atrocities done on the
Dalits and how the atrocities are the
violence acts on women how the women
really you know who is that the lowest
of the society how it adds to the misery
of her life and how she feels it and how
she fights about it and how she comes
out of it and how she organized herself
into be a mode more struggles maybe
leading the struggles this is how my
presentation goes on in South Asia
Dalits have an endure discrimination
based on work decent for centuries and
discrimination continues even till today
caste system declares the elite women to
be intrinsically impure and untouchable
being located at the lowest rung of the
society and morning we are talking about
the landlessness the landlessness
landlessness of the Dallas and the
landless laborers landed labour land the
laborers who have agriculture laborers
working in the fields of the landed
classes engage themselves as daily wage
laborers as women also they have been
subjects of discrimination we have been
talking about triple discrimination as
women as poor and as Dalit women so
these three discrimination she's
subjected to I just want to put exactly
the situation of a Dalit women in the
words of a dollop feminist writer
Cherlapally is very Bharani and this
explains everything
however the little women is leading her
life she says in a poem caught in the
brambles I'm a struggling pala pita
Bluebird whichever way I move all the
thorns prick me alone these are not the
thorns of today they are the shackles of
slavery placed around me from
generations between the devil and the
deep sea
danger always hissed at me and it goes
on and she says that if male arrogance
at home gives me resounding slap on my
cheek one cheek the caste dominance
outside trashes my other cheek when I
went to the fields to earn money by
labour when the landlord there laying
the way to rob me my sweat and me as
well and I wanted to bury myself in the
earth and she goes on saying that I will
purge my life from this in these flames
of trouble and blossom like the monkey
no flower I'll cross the forest of
hardship and search like a stream this
explains precisely how a Dalit women is
feeling today she don't want to be a
silent victim of the atrocities why
she just want to come out of it and live
an individual life coming to the topic
again the major problem that women face
today is the impunity so while the
administrative system fails to implement
laws the perpetrators the dominant
castes enjoy immunity from the
prosecution for well over violence and
subsequently use their political social
and economic power to silence the
victims now we are talking about the
second part of an Thomas is that you
know how they lived women look towards
the mainstream feminist women's movement
because the mainstream feminist women's
movement started in 1970s precisely only
terrorists several issues such as
equality patriarchy and equal wages and
not many but in earlier in answer it
started in 1973 with starting of some of
the organization progressive
organization of women and the
organization of protection of democratic
rights and Sri Shakti sankirtana all the
organizations they do talk about women's
equality but Dalit women is missing in
their discourses and the issues of
Dallas never figured in that movement
nor even in the history in their
struggles rather and they have produced
a plethora of literature which she know
goes on but I think a decade more than a
decade the famous being most of you are
familiar we are making history the
anthology of 40 women fighting for the
lands for the land and for the
livelihood
under the communist party banner but in
that anthology not even a single bellick
women voice is heard not even a single
Dalit women they were in the forefront
of the struggle they were in the
forefront of the struggle against the -
Snooks - - landlords putting law in
their life at stake subjected to rape
and what not but they contribution has
been never been recorded till today
coming to the next part atrocities which
I am going to talk about two cases in
Antrim morning energy was talking about
cinder atrocity and prior to that there
is one more incident happened in 1985
that is scarum.charro
historically of whenever Dalits both
individually as a group they have the
target first nan then with aggression
the dominant upper caste as LAN low land
owners and employees of labour exert
considerable power and Dalits Dallas who
are primarily agricultural laborers work
in their fields are subjected to the
violence then one in Shiva calm is
talking about the dependency is more
vulnerable situation their social and
economic vulnerability of delos provide
readily available ground to the upper
caste to landlords to demonstrate an
exercise power given the power strength
hegemonic relations is with whenever
that is articulated that demands for
higher wages and for increase of wages
or for land distribution they are
subjected to social boycott or denied
access to village natural economic
resources or the atrocities and this is
in the forms of physician Dallas due to
education and employment also triggers
intolerance they could not tolerate the
assertion of the Dallas I'm coming to
Karim thiru this is a incident happen on
July 17 1985 come us that the landed
classes there show their caste basically
but because of their land power they
rose to the prominence and they were in
the government powerful lobby in the
government they attacked the modules of
kerinci do the mario said where are the
sub caste Nanchang
major sub caste through larger
population
official sources quote that but
unofficially it is much more but the
numbers given by the official sources
fight the lit men were killed three
women were raped by the commas several
men and women were injured the post
atrocity struggle was continued from
Chira the I'm not going to talk about
the depiction the reason for this
atrocity is simple a Dalit women
questioning the come a boy who is
putting a pouring the dirty water wash
used for the washing Buffalo into the
drinking tank of belet's
she questions that , boy boy why you are
dirtying the water which is meant for
our drinking purpose this angered the
comma boy and he could not tolerate
questioning of a Dalit women they could
not tolerate the questioning of Delos
and the women is considered still lower
in the castle error so that angered him
went it went back to his village hmm and
again he talked to his fellow man they
came in with arsons and all you know
this someone him his her and her
father-in-law they could not turn up
because it was late the very next day
they came to the village and but you
know kill men the Lippman and rape the
lip women and created such atrocity due
to the this because of this atrocity the
Dallas fled to the next village
Sarala where they formed into they lived
in a severe and then they formed one of
the ant Pradesh dealt mahasabha was
formed from the carnage massacre they
rose to the prominence of you know
organizing themselves and fighting for
their cause and they could not get
justice and it was delayed for so long
twenty long years it took but punishing
very few people these are the some of
the pictures
Karam charity victims that the women
they were beaten badly and yes some of
the women who are raped admitted in the
hospital
these are the pictures from taken from
their newspaper clippings what is more
important here is that the atrocities
been covered by all the major you know
moments they have reaching about the
some of the articles have written about
how the lists were been while the
violence is put on them but the Dalit
women voices were not heard they
questioned the Chief Minister himself
the the littleman questioned the
authorities state authorities and they
say that you know we don't have any
security in our own land so what is the
security for our future generation this
is a question put forth by them and next
some more pictures of parenteral I'll
move on to syndrome Massacre another
Massacre atrocity where again the Dalits
were beaten and 22 the lists were killed
just you know it was again the accession
of the Dalits educated the list which
was not digested by the dominant caste
people the rady's here there are also
landlords official sources say the age
but the unofficially they're 22 persons
were missing in syndrome Massacre I will
move on to the pictures where you know
the women the victims question in the
state authorities again they want
justice not welfare the little women
questions that self self respect is more
important than material benefits then
moving towards the lit women leadership
oh I'm sorry I'm unable to explain how
the lit women could take that atrocity
but coming to the positive aspect of the
lit women assertion
going to talk about two instance where
you know anti-iraq hesitation and
another is a land struggle this entire
record station the impact I am going to
just you know in during 1990s the Dalit
women took themselves the curtilage of
leader this leadership in this people's
moment fought against a stage and were
instrumental in bringing down the
government this became one of the
election agenda this is different from
the brahmanic legend of you know keeping
away from liquor is as a ethical point
this is not the case with Dalit women
they want to they want they're meant to
be away from liquor because it is a
livelihood issue because the government
initiated who are inavaja nee selling of
the liquor ain't given the liquor per
our pockets in place of wages this is
one of the issue which they know the
equipment got affected their livelihood
got affected the poor women were the
worst victims and then they took the
they fought against the state government
again correct this is one of the biggest
moment ever taken by women especially
the delyth women these are some of the
cases some of the photos where the women
fighting against stage and some photos
where you know people who are tied this
is the most important struggle which
he'll explain in a minute mother is
struggled by Deluth women where you know
they fought against the land they wanted
to cultivate the government as in land
and then but ready suppose this the
dominant castes opposed it
but they fought against it and they won
the struggle I am sorry I can't explain
it much because the clippings are there
what are the demands they put humidity
arrest of these landlords and because
the landlords they
again you know the struggle is based on
land issue and for the first time gender
issues linked this is what I want to
focus on there are so severe land of
like you know communists have taken the
land issue distribution of land to the
village but never been in the history
that gender is linked to the land issue
in mother struggle showed the way to the
Communists struggle also by linking the
gender issue also how important is a
land for the little men
so they demanded the land entitlements
on their name not in the name of the
husband's but on their name this is
precisely what I want to talk about this
is some of the photos of their struggle
coming to the last part the polar Pelle
says the lip victims again morning I was
talking about that why women so in
conclusion I will just take a minute
hmm what it means why I am showing this
four different struggles is that three
important issues the dealt women put
forth in front of the woman's moment and
in front of the Dalit moment one is that
valid women are being used as an object
of sex and violence it is significant to
note that modesty of the Leatherman is
outraged and being just affairs as
simple and insignificant issue never
been the modesty of the little minis
discussed and big agenda or you know
never been it is looked upon as a simple
matter that in women is raped every day
Smith and Narula recent finding says
that daily relative men is being taped
but it's only a news for everybody but
not an issue to be taken seriously the
issue of modesty of delyth women was
never considered for debate
paradoxically modesty of upper caste
women is considered high so dude I
forgot to tell you that why children
load was taken so serious turn because
the Dalit boy they say that you know the
Dalit boy is the dominant caste
women this is precisely the reason for
the atrocity they say that a boy teased
the upper caste women which was not
supposed to do that and they say that
you know the this is how the embed kebab
Oetker says that and the dominant caste
women's sexuality is been closely
guarded hmm and he gave a statement that
they know women are the gateways of
caste system by saying so he says that
women's sexuality is being closely
guarded by opposing the end okay I'm
sorry
upper dominant caste women are reported
to have marched in straight declaring
their modesty have been authorized to
endure incident and this has been
brought out by magical birth in her book
in conclusion there is a significant
shift from being vulnerable silent group
to a group attempting to make a
consolidated organized articulation by
the Dalit women in answer the elite
women question patriarchal mindset of
development for not adequately spacing
that modesty in the struggle and they'll
if women also articulations are carried
out with reference to family society and
state whereas dumb dominant caste women
largely talked about in the family and
Delhi Thurman leadership is not adequate
for adequate space in the late moments
in which we can see him soon do it Karen
shadow several women were in for French
fighting for justice with a gun went
directly ELISA mind all but never they
were in the forefront as leaders of the
movement and now it to conclude the
missing I measured the progress of women
Barbossa of ambit this world I measured
the progress of achieved by the women
progress of any community with the
progress achieved by the women
especially here this is in 1942 Delap
the Mahela federation he says that that
any progress of the community can be
measured by the progress made by the the
liquor man thank you for very much for
your patience here
I'm sorry if I'm missing any links I
can't read because of tiny Penn State
thank you I apologize for having to cut
cut people off or forcing them to
shorten their points but I think many of
these issues will come up in the context
of our conversation and so I hope so
that we'll be able to open up some of
these issues she's brought up in the
context of our collective conversations
thank you once again to the organizers
of this conference and my favorite buyer
Joe Ali for his invitation my
presentation is going to be on a delete
woman writer critical constructive
narratives by Obama interweaving a
liberation of visible bodies and
silenced voices as texture for delete
women's freedom I start with a quote
from this delete woman writer Cole Bhama
we believed what they told us repeatedly
that we are useless chicken scratching
about in the rubbish and now we have no
confidence in ourselves at least from
now on we must stand for ourselves
if ever there is a problem or a
disturbance everyone starting with the
police chooses to blame and humiliate
the women of our community the
government does not seem to be prepared
to address any of this so we must take
up the challenge ourselves in court I
discuss Bhama adalat woman writer born
in 1958 who writes and Darla's thumber
literature as a testimonial voice of
Dalit women struggle for a personal
sense of identity and a collective claim
for human dignity Varma published
carrucha in 1992 that speaks of the
experiences of Christianity as was
nominated for her through Catholicism
she exposes ways in which both Hinduism
and Christianity controls their lives as
dullards she describes her experiences
as a Catholic nun and the prevalence of
caste in the nunnery that angered her so
much that she just had to leave in
Sangha thehe published in 1996 Varma
straights the everyday lives and
struggles of Dalit women in her village
of puttaparthi in Tamil Nadu and what
validates bama's written narratives is
the fact that they consciously transform
a simple narration of a life story into
a construction of the history of a
people in my larger paper I interweave
two forms of her narratives her written
text and her oral narratives through
personal interviews for the purpose of
this brief presentation however I dwell
on her narrative Sangha 'they which
literally means news or events
bama's writings are testimonial
narratives that interweave the
visibility of women's bodies and
silencing of women's voices in their
struggle for identity and dignity in
Sangha thei Varma lays out a social and
cultural map of the Piraeus
to the party she brings to focus the
exploitation of Dalit women by the upper
caste masters as well as the faithful
delete male servants of the landlords
who replicate their masters violent
authority on their women thus Dalit
women become the doubly oppressed or the
sub gender being fuel and Varma however
also galvanizes the lead women as
socio-political actors in their demand
for justice and in their expression of
resistance I will focus on two
mechanisms that Burma employs to convey
the forceful purpose of a narratives her
presentation of Dalit women's bodies and
their voices Varma creates a persuasive
methodological process that interweaves
non dominant voices and discourses
voices of Dalit men and women voices of
young resistant elite curves and the
older experienced resilient voices of
women voices of Dalit cultural strengths
revealed in songs and rituals narratives
emerging from forced silences and caused
internal our internalization
the intermixing of the voices of Dalit
Hinduism and Christianity as both
oppressive and liberating and the voice
of alternative teachings of the
liberating Christianity as opposed to
the misappropriation of such teachings
by oppressive sectors and Christianity
such interweaving of voices renders
Varma's narratives as stories that are
credible durable and rich in their
landing of layers of variations of the
complexities of the lives of 33 men in
her interview Varma was insistent the
Dalit women are not silent women but
have always been speaking in their
cultural languages that they tell and
retell their stories and songs folk
tales dances and laments but there are
silenced voices rather who continue with
their discourse of resistance to only
those who will hear due to their fear of
authority among the various voices we
hear in Burma's Sangha 'they her
grandmother or party which the Tamil
word for grandmothers the most
significant voice she is the voice of
tradition the authoritative questioning
voice from the margins who has unwarily
internalized the caste reality in the
argumentative voices of both Varma and
her grandmother we see how these
textures present her community to a
larger world interwoven with Allah's
vulnerabilities and resistance strengths
and weaknesses determination and
dilemmas the party represents the
unadulterated indigenous strategies of
survival but still within the cultural
specifications that inform her
consciousness of her life controlled by
social hierarchy and within that she
learns that she has to continue to speak
and be heard by other dilip women to
create and share in a discourse of
survival for Bhama these are enduring
cultural elements that need to be
recognized and claimed but elite women
for a transformative change i used the
word visibility in reference to Dalia to
women's bodies to qualify the corollary
of the estate of invisibility
tucked away Invisibles in invisible
spaces in addition to notions that Bhama
exposes the invisibility of Tollett
women I argue and add that bomber also
chooses to highlight the visibility of
Dalit women's bodies and I attempt to
extract the layers of meanings as I
describe these bodies detailed in
bombers narratives
first of all bombers idea of visibility
is a celebration of Dalit female body
and sexuality as she meticulously
details for the reader
Dalit cultural
this is in rituals and in that her body
is a positive cultural construct where
the invisible markers of subversive
discourses that reject dominant
traditional images of their bodies as
polluted immoral and dispensable
secondly domicile details ways in which
Dalit women are objects of selective
visibility subject to even selectively
touch ability as targets for sexual
pleasure and attack for the oppressive
powers that surround them the
invisibility is in relation to their
immediate surroundings and I do not
however undermine the estate of
invisibility to the rest of the world
Bhama also simultaneously both reveals
as well as stills new grounds whether
it's female identity can and will thrive
through active resistance to sanctioned
imposed identities versus just an
irksome coping Insung the obama
interweave such notions of Dalit female
body and voice in the story of a young
Dalit girl called Mary Emma whose new
cousin who's 15 years old
Mariama after long day's work in the
fields returns home one evening passing
by a water pump shed in the fields and
her landlord who happens to be in the
water shed tries to lure her into the
shed
somehow Maruyama escapes and runs into
her village and tells about the incident
to her close friends they advise her to
remain silent because this would
demoralize her since she was young and
of multiple age and these girls are just
about 13 to 16 years of age for young
delete girls silence becomes their only
protection from further harm the silence
is a discourse in itself a testimony to
the knowledge of caste patriarchal power
and their helplessness the event takes a
twist however when a landlord fearing
blemish to his name reports to the
village headman adalat that young Dalit
girls who passes fields often misbehave
he alleges that he saw Maruyama
physically intimate with a young lad
Monika both of them are made to appear
before the village council made up of
Dalit men for a trial
it is Mariama who's publicly humiliated
and blamed of misconduct she's asked to
beg forgiveness by falling at the
headman's feet and pay a fine of 200
rupees at the trial the visibility and
loud Authority of the upper caste
landlord despite the fact that he's not
even physically present at the trial is
a stark reality
Mariama however tries to speak for
herself as she is questioned she
concedes what that much on says is true
when I was gathering firewood in a few
with a few others he said a word or two
to me in fun I came away before the
others left Varma writes I quote if
Maruyama had said any more she would
have burst into tears she finished
speaking wiped her face with her saree
and stood there her head drooping in
court unconvinced the council insist
that she fall at the feet of the headman
and beg forgiveness and pay the fine if
she did not comply her father would have
to pay a lot more money as penalty and
so far the forces had a big forgiveness
she maintains her innocence saying I
never did any of that it was the
mudalali who tried to misbehave with me
but I escaped from him and ran away she
began to weep loudly Maruyama speaks to
defend her honor and dignity but the
highlighted inscription on her body of
blame shame and humiliation spoke louder
than her actual attempts to speak
throwing her into a state of silent
visibility but her submissive body
carries a powerful message to the rest
of the community her body is used to
both blame the victim and to redeem the
village of poverty through forceful
acceptance of that blame she's aware of
the situation tries to speak the truth
but speak is not edifying instead it is
defeated as a self justifying ploy now
this incident leads us beyond dual
conclusions into reading of multiple
meanings as Miriam of falls at the feet
of the headman she literally carries the
science of patriarchal culture on her
back as she bends breaks and finally
even false prostrating herself to
perform her religiously and culturally
sanctioned original natural definition
of being polluted and immoral while this
drama of blame unfolds the landlord is
his house sheltered in the paraphernalia
of caste patriarchy at all the Landlord
re-establishes the pattern of this
visibility of defeat and the hyper
visibility of a sovereignty and it is
this culture of defeat and shame that
Maruyama embodies she is surrounded by
the emasculated masculinity of Dalit men
who make up for it in accusing her due
to fear of losing their ties with the
landlord but at the same time she's
surrounded by the physical presence and
rebellious voices of Dal eat women that
they dare not raise among men but they
provide the moral affirmation that she
needs at that time when Dalit women do
speak their voice is invalidated one
woman on and Amma says it was the model
Ali who tried to rape her she was scared
out of her wits to fuse him and ran away
and now he's turned everything around
and told a different tale I actually
went with her that evening
Susie Amma says what can you say to
these men there is no way of convincing
them but it's only to us that they'll
brag ask them to stand up to their
mudalali they'll cover their mouths and
their backsides and they'll run and
court they do not accuse the men openly
but only in muffled whispers as bomber
recalls so Bob Mariama must accept this
accusation so that the colony may be
spared the threats of violence if they
were to let her go under prime ANDed one
the little woman says and none of them
has the brains to find out whether it
was in the mudalali who was doing wrong
in the first place another one says who
do you think is going to win even if the
mother Lally was really at fault so does
Mary MA who stands Dignitas humiliated
and morally mutilated as yet another
immoral tallit woman as we know this
practice of displaying the elite women's
bodies of parading them naked is quite
common in rural india every time this
happens caste based patriarchal systems
of authority is Rhian what all
authoritative and powerful structures
converge on her body
therefore aztecs bodies of Dalit women
are sites of power struggles sites of
traditional and emerging caste ruling
orders and sites of cultural demarcation
hence in the very process but Dalit
women's bodies are made
sites of violence a deep sense of
collectivity of voices those silenced
proves to be the strength that subverts
the dominant notion that their bodies
can be formulated as texts of violence
to make a statement to the community
therefore their bodies morph into
billboards that carry a terrifying
message to warn their larger community
as a public statement is made in
punishing her body in making it public
spectacle therefore remaining within
once defined spaces crucial to prove
one's medians to a set of rules when
women cross over their gendered spaces
as active agents in claiming their
rights or dignity tis unacceptable so it
is the meanings of boundaries and
markers that one wrestles with in such
situations where interactions between
communities are solely based on power
equations the undercurrent that actually
informs these interactions is complex
but nevertheless the consequences of
non-compliance to boundaries are
straightforward the interplay of women's
social identities between visible
invisible touchable untouchable laborers
sex provider labor bondage dispensable
indispensable reveal ambiguities that
not only affect but that allow for the
creation of new categories of difference
is mainly for women and the elite
women's bodies are configured as
autonomous spaces to inscribe
conflicting meanings to suit the needs
of the dominant male so in the culture
that bomber seeks to reiterate cultural
strands drawn from the communities
beliefs and practices testify to a
personal sense of identity that Reza's
dominant culture Obama seeks to tap into
the cultural strengths that the
grandmother and other Dalit women embody
through emerging from the experiences of
being silenced and victimized so the
elite women self-consciousness must be
inverted by reversing mechanisms and
strategies of social and religious
constructions that keep them at the
bottom creative explorations reanimated
the silences and recover their bodies
through existing cultural strengths
pointing us to more equitable and
life-affirming possibilities
our final speaker is Rita Narula thank
you I apologize that I was a little bit
late John he said she came from a
military family so it's always on time I
came from a UN family so we do things
that our own but I apologize for holding
you up I wanted to begin by thanking the
organizers and just to reiterate what
other panelists have said it is this is
truly a historic event to be here today
to honor dr. Ambedkar to do so at
Columbia University and for me just to
be in the company of so many thinkers
and activists from whom I've learned so
much over the years so thank you and
thank you Joel for inviting me in
particular
last week the High Commissioner for
Human Rights Navi Pillay issued a
groundbreaking statement called
tearing down the wall of caste in which
she called on the international
community to come together to support
efforts to tear down caste
discrimination as it did when it helped
put an end to apartheid the statement
was a monumental one because it was the
first time that a person in her position
which is the highest UN related Human
Rights position came out and made such a
comprehensive call for all caste
affected countries to take on the task
of implementing human rights and for the
protection of the 'lets but also for the
international community to come together
in service of that project
it was also contained within that
statement was a not-so-veiled reference
to India's attitude this entire time by
saying that the nature of the atrocities
against the millions of individuals that
she was referring to cannot simply be
swept under the rug as family business
which has essentially been India's take
on the international stage this is a
family affair please do not intervene in
our personal situations and by the way
we have a very progressive Constitution
and reservations and therefore the
problem has self corrected itself that
moment had many markers preceding it and
the women's rights movement has played a
significant role in all the markers
before coming to that
and of course there was the the
formidable presence of Dalit women
rights activate at the Beijing World
Conference there was the the work of the
Ambedkar center for justice and peace
and bringing these issues before the
Committee on the Elimination of Racial
Discrimination in 1996 and the first
time that a UN committee was forced to
articulate how all these bodies of
international human rights law applied
to this population of two hundred and
sixty million people in South Asia even
though the term caste does not appear
once in a single International Human
Rights document other markers along the
way have been the world conference
against racism in South Africa in Durban
where the Dalit movement really came on
the international stage and and set
itself up as one of the premier human
rights challenges in which the
international community must play a role
and since then there have been many
individual markers along with
information presented two different
treaty bodies the naming of Special
Rapporteurs at the UN to specifically
deal with work and dissent based
discrimination and the momentum has been
building where did this momentum come
from and how have dalek women played a
role therein so how we got to that point
has been it's been I think a marriage
between international and and local
actors not just from India but also from
Nepal and Pakistan Bangladesh and Sri
Lanka from Japan from African countries
lest we not forget that caste is not
just an India issue but a
sub-continental issue and even a broader
continent and African issue as well and
it got to that point
after many articulations by the late
women's rights group who stemming from
the stage and so that made a very
compelling presentation of showing the
ways in which that women have always
been at the forefront of struggles at
the village level at the community level
and also increasingly at the national
level heading national anti anti in
touch ability campaigns economic rights
campaigns the National Federation for
those women being one prominent example
of such campaigns and that has now
spilled over into the international
arena and just as dalek women have had
to contend with women's rights groups in
India to find a space they now also have
to contend with other rights groups to
find a space without women's issue
and in bringing Dalit women leadership
within that rights group bringing these
issues on the international scene there
are two narratives that are very common
to the LAT woman's approach to bringing
these issues into the international
arena and those narratives are
descriptive and they lead to a
particular prescription which I'll talk
about in a moment
the descriptive part of it has to do as
I see it has to do with showing the
impunity for the acts of violence that
have been so pointedly described in
narrative form by Rocha and also in the
form of movements and and the slides
that so that showed that the impunity
for those acts of violence is has been
the gap between constitutional vision
and social reality in India so all of
these constitutions all of the laws that
exist too and that hide the real face of
democracy in India that the the huge gap
between those laws and the reality of
the other's lives and the impunity that
that marks is the narrative of the late
women and that has been part of the
human rights conversation and part of
the invitation of international human
rights into into the into Indian
villages the part of that narrative also
includes statistics such as 13 dollars
are murdered every week five homes are
destroyed three women are raped 11
bullets are assaulted and a crime is
committed every 18 minutes against
Dalits I'll come back to those
statistics in a moment the second part
of that narrative is one of economic
exploitation and it's of showing the
ways in which women form the majority of
manual scavengers in the country manual
scavenging as a caste based occupation
really reveals some of the issues of
economic abuse and exploitation and the
ways in which purity and pollution work
into caste-based discrimination and
occupation in a way that's very poignant
and very telling for the caste system as
a whole it's also very telling that even
as India is continues to grow even under
global economic recession and is sending
spaceships into space and and doing all
the things floating nuclear weapons
underground that the number of manual
scavengers simultaneously is increasing
in the country so you have to ask
yourself is this a problem of lack of
technology or lack of resources or lack
of sanitation or does manual scavenging
exist as a practice because and will it
always exist because there will always
be people to do that job and there will
always be a reason to keep them in those
jobs because it satisfies a broader
economic exploitation project those are
some of the questions that though that
women are bringing to the forefront of
the conversation um the other part of
that conversation is also the ways in
which India's aggressive economic
reforms and indeed its entire
socio-economic development project has
largely either by postulates or has been
servicing an elite dominant caste at the
exploitation and at the expense of the
elites and dr. Tilton day has written a
great deal about that as well then if
that's the description then a few things
that other sort of narratives that come
into play so there's the impunity
conversation and there's the economics
exploitation conversation and underlying
all of that is what I see as a message
that needs to be drawn out that that
when you talk about caste and gender in
India it is not just a conversation
about women it may seem that way because
it's an all women panel but gender as
last I checked also was about men and it
is also about the recognizing and this
goes to the very the statement of
Ambedkar that so that just put up that
unless you deal with violence against
women which is where the heart of
impunity lies and the ways in which
violence is meted out on their bodies
and they become the battlegrounds you
will not deal with impunity and you will
not deal with rule of law in India
unless you deal with economic issues as
they relate to women and land rights as
they relate to women and labor as it
relates to women you will not deal with
the the caste based occupation and the
route of economic exploitation that is
the caste system in India so the issue
of gender and caste is not a side issue
that needs to be discussed as a special
kind of victimization even though it is
a special kind of victimization the
narrative is really one of recognizing
that until some of those
issues are addressed at the state level
at the society level but also in the
home and the patriarchy within the lit
families and within the Dalit leadership
level then some of these broader issues
are not going to get resolved that I
think has been one of the main
contributions and I just want to remind
you of that narrative as we talk about
gender and caste in this conference
today so what does it mean then to take
that narrative and then to say okay
international human rights law is now
going to is it going to resolve and is
it going to succeed where economic
projects have failed and where
constitutional projects have failed and
my answer to that question is is no but
it can succeed it's not going to succeed
if it is confined to the moral and legal
constraints of the of the regime in
which human rights now lives but it does
have the potential for social
transformation if we step outside the
box when we talk about human rights so
let me start by the constraints human
rights law is and the idea of human
rights is organized around this idea
that the state has positive obligations
to ensure non-discrimination and
equality that the state must intervene
in the lives of its citizens and and by
promulgating laws and enforcing those
laws that that will trickle down to the
rest of the population and equality will
be guaranteed how does that work in
countries like India where the rule of
caste sabotage is the rule of law on a
daily basis Human Rights also assumes
that the state is a neutral actor and
that the state and and this has already
been said earlier today that the state
is a friend to though it's in the state
will actually be coming in in service of
the Equality project without recognizing
that the state itself is a replication
of the very caste order in hierarchy
that itself has been charged with
dismantling that very challenge and the
fundamental challenge that human rights
is of is the form of equality promoted
by human rights is in direct opposition
to the form of graded inequality that
the caste system represents clashes on
the Indian stage and in villages across
the country to the detriment of security
of citizenship rights for Dalits as a
whole
there you know many people also talk
about democracy they talk about other
ways in which India has progressed so
much and here part of what the Dalit
women's narrative has done is to really
lay bare that India is a different
country and there are many different
India's depending on how it is lived by
the communities that make up that fabric
it's a very different country for
dominant caste and than it is for Dalits
it's a different country for men than it
is for women for rich than it is for
poor and the ways in which Dalits are
constantly pushed into a state of
exception there means that they cannot
access those particular rights that
citizens and citizenship in a democracy
can't afford I'll quickly come to sort
of one of the why I think even with all
those even with all of those limitations
how I think human rights could possibly
be a transformative project um but first
to say to sort of explain where I think
it has fallen down the it falls down by
relying on the state to be a neutral
actor and by relying on the fact that
just by saying that particular law z'
once they've been put into place will
actually do the trick
it also falls down by not taking into
account that the state is shrinking in
some ways in other ways it's growing but
what about the private sector where do
human rights go when state obligations
don't travel with the privatization of
certain services to the private sector
it is you know feminists have long
argued and have tried to bring human
rights into the home but again it's much
more difficult to have laws that govern
those personal relationships and have a
human rights conversation when when it's
really about family business or domestic
affairs um so where does that leave us
and where does that leave somebody like
me who's actually been doing human
rights activism for a very long time and
where do I come out thinking about this
I come out thinking about it that it's
um that moving from description to
prescription it is essential that the
international community stay involved it
is essential that that partnership
raises the voices of those who are
already doing this work and have been
doing this work for centuries actually
from within but it's important not to
set our sights on the bottom of the
system
and here I wanted to quote Ambedkar um
in one passage that he said that that
always resonates with me which was it is
usual to hear all those who feel moved
by the deplorable condition of the
untouchables unburdened themselves by
uttering the cry we must do something
for the untouchables one seldom hears of
any of the persons interested in the
problem saying let us do something to
change the touchable Hindu and this
quotes and and this philosophy is
familiar to many of you in the room if I
were to translate that and transpose it
on to what human rights needs to do what
it says to me is that we shouldn't just
be setting our sights on the victims and
and end on protections for the victims
where is the space of human rights about
actually bringing the bigoted mindset
into the room and treating as the
problem the dominant caste and their
caste as prejudice and their mindset we
often refer to that it says former
Untouchables there is no former Brahmin
legally or otherwise we also talk about
reservations as reserving in proportion
to their population particular
privileges or seats for Dalits and OB
sees what if we were just to reserve in
proportion to their population seats for
upper caste Hindus wouldn't that take
care of the problem entirely so I bring
some of those out as examples of the way
in which I think there needs to be a
fundamental shift and I think human
rights in cooperation with the struggles
that have already been foregrounded by
the LAT women and that have already had
the both the experience as those who
receive caste atrocities but also as
those who keep their homes going and who
keep the economy's going ruth Manorama
always talks about how india was built
on on the backs of Dalit women and in
their labor taking those experiences and
seeing how they have fought for those
transformations and not just leaving the
other part of the equation off there is
something between the state and between
the victim and that's much of society
which I think Human Rights has largely
ignored um I'll end there and just ask
us all to please bring that back in and
to remember that gender caste is gender
in caste is is not just part of the
equation it is
answer to the equation thank you
you